the Black Panther has been the protector
of Wakanda for generations it's time to
ensure the outside world
now that I have your attention
[Music]
everybody we got new Black Panther
footage to break down but there's also a
whole bunch of Tom Hardy venom
spider-verse movie stuff that just
dropped so I wanted to do a video for
that but then all this Black Panther
stuff drop so I figured I'd just do one
video for everything so get hype this is
so awesome if you're just finding me for
the first time we do Marvel every week
be sure to subscribe to get everything
there's a bunch of infinity war and
Black Panther stuff coming up between
all the Star Wars stuff starting with
black panther footage first he
highlights the lineage of the black
panther they've been doing this for
generations now it's my turn
we need to show the world who we are so
it's sort of like Wakanda is coming out
ceremony in the MCU like open the doors
wide and then everybody get a peek and
why we're so badass you get a little bit
more of him in the new energy costume
you see it forming around to him this
footage is a little bit better than the
footage in my last video it's just a
little more polished you can see his
armor forming around him the way that
Iron Man's armor forms around him but I
love that clip of Lupita who's one of
the dorm Ellijay howling with delight
behind the wheel of that car like dude
or Milosh AR hardcore they're so
measured in balance you see them during
Civil War they look like they don't talk
much but obviously that's not true
because she's having the time of her
life here so they're just really badass
fighters we'll get to see some more
their personality during the Black
Panther movie you didn't get a whole lot
of that during civil war but that aside
they probably just dropped this to
highlight the Lexus stuff because
they're doing a partnership with Lexus
the car and they paid like millions and
millions of dollars to get that into the
Black Panther movie so if you wonder why
Black Panther characters love Lexus cars
so much it's just because they pay a ton
of money it's the same way that Audi
paid a ton of money to get their cars
into the Iron Man movies but moving into
spider-man venom territory we know what
stories is going to be based on and that
gives us an idea for how they're going
to explain what's going on with MCU Tom
Hollands spider-man while you have all
this other spider-man stuff going on so
I know we went through all those Kevin
Feige memes earlier this year when Amy
Pascal so that the universes were
connected so the way they're treating
this makes it easier for them to not
have to worry about why spider-man isn't
around like if they're swinging around
New York City without addressing
MCU stuff so when you hear the stories
that it's based on it will totally make
sense how this fits in and speaking of
fitting in news outlets are starting to
report that the Disney Fox deal will be
confirmed on Thursday I don't know if
that's gonna happen but I'll explain a
little bit about the status of that at
the end of the video but starting with
the big stuff first the origin story so
everybody knows a version of the Eddie
Brock origin story or maybe you know
about venom space night because you've
been reading the guardians of the galaxy
comics in the last couple of years so
the whole deal is that the symbiote
bonds with spider-man
during secret Wars it gets back to earth
riding on his back like he learns all
about the symbiote learns that it's evil
tries to get rid of it then it bonds
with Eddie Brock then much much later
the government starts a program called
project rebirth 2.0 where they bond the
Venom symbiote to Flash Thompson who at
this point is a war veteran he's a
double amputee so he has nothing left to
lose he's like I just want to get back
in the game and he becomes agent venom a
government controlled version of the
venom character technically venom within
these new Sony movies that they're doing
is going to be the anti-hero version of
the character he'll be more like agent
venom so the minor change they're making
is that Eddie Brock is probably going to
be a war vet who's given an opportunity
to get back in the game via the Venom
symbiote but the two comic book runs
that they're basing the movie on are
venom lethal protector in Planet of the
symbiotes so that sort of explains how
the symbiote gets to Planet Earth how
the government gets their hands on it
and how he winds up becoming bonded with
it so it sounds like they're bypassing
Secret Wars so that if they ever
actually do want to cross venom over
with Tom Hollands version of spider-man
they can do the Tom Hardy version so I
can understand if you're a little upset
about that they're not going to do the
secret Wars symbiote Tom Hall it won't
get a version of that because the suit
that he is wearing during infinity war
the iron spider stark tech suit looks
just like the brand-new version in the
comics and it seems like he's going to
be wearing that for the foreseeable
future if you've never read the lethal
protector storyline it's basically venom
versus five of the offspring of the
Venom symbiote scream phage riot Lasher
in agony so in that storyline venom
teams up with spider-man to take down
the offspring of his own
symbiotes but we actually found out that
carnage is probably going to be the big
villain of the venom movie he is a part
of the Planet of the symbiotes storyline
in what I think will happen is is
because in that storyline a bunch of
symbiotes literally fall to earth that's
how they'll explain the symbiote getting
on planet earth in the government
getting their hands on it in how that
might explain the carnage character in
these five offspring is the government
just experimenting with the symbiote in
a couple of the experiments getting
loose so they have their agent venom
Eddie Brock Tom Hardy that has to go
take them down so it's sort of a seek
and destroy
venom movie and carnage will just be one
of the worst versions of those symbiotes
but you guys can let me know what you
think about them treating the character
that way but within those two stories is
the key to how this character can
coexist with Tom Hollands spider-man and
they don't have to address the
continuity they don't have to say hey
wait you're spider-man
so I've already explained how the
symbiote gets to Planet Earth how Eddie
Brock gets it but there's the addition
of New York City that's your problem
geography if he's in proximity to
spider-man how do you explain spider-man
not coming around in the lethal
protector storyline spider-man tells
venom I'll leave you alone if you leave
New York City so he goes to San
Francisco so it sounds like that's what
they'll do what the movie is it'll be
set in San Francisco or somewhere that's
not New York City so you don't have to
explain spider-man and they can set it
during a time period that's not
surrounding infinity war so you don't
have to deal with that stuff either like
holy crap I got to chase down all these
symbiotes and there's a purple man
coming down from the sky they just won't
have to deal with any of that and then
if they want to they can just cross the
characters over think bond continuity
James Bond movies all exist in a shared
continuity but the films themselves
don't directly address all the events
that have happened before with very few
exceptions so that is how the spider
verse can coexist with the MCU so just
to differentiate between the two
different story universes so when you're
talking about Tom Hollands spider-man
spider-man homecoming franchise that's
all MCU everything else the animated
movie into the spider verse that they're
doing with Miles Morales the venom
movies that they're doing Sony's calling
that the spider verse
so they can actually cross the
spider-verse over with the MCU if
there's ever a good opportunity for that
but because Sony wants to make so many
movies with the spider-man characters
and you can only cross so many
characters over in the MCU it just gets
too complicated so the easiest way to
deal with that is to say a spider-verse
MCU one or two characters maybe crossing
over down the line but for the most part
the stories of those different universes
won't directly address what each other
is doing but here's the big thing though
moving into that Disney Foxx deal that
actually might wind up going through
tomorrow if they get the Fox characters
that means they can do a legit Secret
Wars Avengers movie down the road now
because the movie like that is so big it
would be crazy I'm not expecting them to
try that anytime soon but it's just the
idea that they can do that at some point
now a lot of you have said maybe there's
a problem with the Fantastic Four
characters because a different company
owns the rights to that than Fox so it's
a bit of a complicated situation so
within the box x-men group of characters
Fantastic Four is a bit of an aberration
but it's just more complicated it
doesn't mean that Marvel won't get to
use those characters it just requires a
couple more hoops for them to jump
through but all the trades are reporting
that the deal is at the stage where
they've already agreed on the really big
terms and now they're just haggling on
all the little stuff in the fine print
so we'll probably hear some really big
news in the next couple of days when we
do I will totally do a reaction video
because it is probably the biggest thing
to happen in the last couple of years
but of course it's Star Wars week make
sure you go see that movie I'll be
posting a whole bunch of Star Wars
videos in the next couple of days once
people get a chance to see it I'll start
doing the more spoilery stuff I'll talk
about the ending of the movie the big
questions that it raises but leave all
your requests in the comments below and
there is a new round of that imax ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a spider-man
related comment on the video I'll
announce a winner the next time I post a
Marvel video you can click here for my
non-spoilery last Jedi review and you
can click here to rewatch that
spider-man spider first trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]